Welcome back everyone it's charlie the black widow
movie has finally been released you can finally go
see marvel movies in theaters or on disney plus
if you want this is going to be my video for the
ending in the post credit scene because it's a big
link to marvel phase 4 and stuff that's happening
in the future some of the stuff it connects to
we've actually already seen if you're brand new to
the channel i do marvel videos every week there's
a bunch of huge stuff coming up with the loki
finale the marvel what if episodes and even more
relevant to what's happening during this video
the other stuff that the post-credits scene in
black widow is linking up to later this year so
we won't have to wait that long for marvel to pay
off what they're setting up in the post-credits
scene careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the movie yet because i'll be talking about
everything from the movie all the stuff that they
set up i'll just number these easter eggs moments
as we go along to stay organized starting at the
end of the movie so drakoff is the main villain of
the film even though it takes a while for her to
actually get to him in the red room natasha black
widow's whole arc in the movie is just clearing
out all the emotional baggage and the loose ends
she left when she defected to the united states
and shield with hawkeye and nick fury's help back
during the early 2000s she had previously thought
that she had killed dracoff because her mission
as she explains it was the infamous budapest story
that she and hawkeye kept referencing in all the
avengers movies her last act in defecting to the
u.s and getting nick fury to sign off on it was
to kill drakoff in budapest with hawkeye's help
and she says they destroyed the entire city just
to get to him and blew up the whole building he
was in but apparently she never bothered to check
for a body and they explained there's this weird
pheromone that drake off gives off that prevents
the black widows from harming him physically so
the way she explains it she thought the body was
vaporized but also there might have been some of
that pheromone work at play just kind of making
her forget what actually happened to the body
it is part of the big taskmaster reveal don't
worry we'll talk about taskmaster in a second
too her attempt to kill him was to hide a bomb
in drakoff's daughter's backpack and at the time
she was just a little school girl visiting him
at his office in budapest so she spent all
these years thinking that she killed this little
innocent girl who didn't do anything wrong just
to get to drake off and that was meant to be what
loki was taunting her with when he referenced
drakov's daughter in the first avengers movie
she also spent all these years thinking that the
red room itself had been destroyed but as she also
finds out that was not the case as well because
drakov survived and his daughter survived antonia
and at the end of the movie basically black widow
yelling at belova red guardian molina pull a faint
on drakoff using an oldie but a goodie the black
widow face swap trick from captain america winter
soldier they also used that same twist just a
little while ago on falcon winter soldier with
sharon carter more on that stuff too in a second
because the post-credits scene was also originally
meant to set up falcon winter soldier and another
upcoming disney plus series for later this year
even though they had to reshuffle things with
the way they released the marvel movies like the
delayed the black widow movie whole bunch they
never changed anything about the black widow
film the post credit scene was always what it was
going to be the end of the movie was always what
it was going to be natasha is able to get all this
data on sleeper agent black widows that drakov has
around the world and there are hundreds of them
and the new version of the red room in present
day has been chemically altering their brains to
turn them into glorified finger puppets controlled
remotely from the red room by drakoff himself
i'd say they like robots like the clones from
star wars but they're not clones and the only one
who actually has a chip in its brain or in its
head is antonia but he does actually have kill
switch commands built into them he has certain
commands built into them that he can call out
order them to do very specific tasks the idea
is that it's basically chemical brainwashing he
also says that he wants to do this to natasha now
so that he'll have an avenger that's his secret
sleeper agent remember though this is happening
before the events of avengers infinity war so it
does kind of hurt the stakes a little bit that you
know that this isn't going to come to pass so part
of the end of the movie though is in getting the
locations and identities of all these sleeper
agents tell in a belova and a sample of the
antidote to free them from their conditioning the
chemical brainwashing so that they can deactivate
all these sleeper agents without having to kill
them and truly end the legacy of the red room
but the other big reveal being that drakoff was
able to avoid the avengers all these years not
only because he didn't engage them specifically
like he kept all of his sleeper agents away from
them so that he wouldn't land on their radar
but also literally wouldn't land on their radar
because the red room itself is also kind of a
discount helicarrier that moves above cloud level
all over the earth all the time to avoid detection
from any of earth's systems so the idea was is
that he was also evading nick fury's detection as
well but while this is happening dracop reveals
that taskmaster is actually his daughter antonia
who survived the blast in budapest that almost
killed him and during her recovery he had to put
a chip in her neck and basically had to completely
rewire her whole brain just so that she could
live day to day but that also gave him the idea
for the taskmaster protocol which is the way
they explain taskmaster's abilities in the mcu
so obviously it's a big change to taskmaster from
the comics in the comics taskmaster's name is tony
masters see what they did there tony antonia but
he's a former shield agent turned mercenary and
technically he doesn't have any special powers his
ability to copy people's moves is because he has
photographic reflexes sort of like a boss level
upgrade to having photographic memory so in the
mcu taskmaster is mostly the suit the protocol
the technology you see the heads-up display
feeding her information real-time data from
fights and giving her suggestions and orders
on how to defeat whoever it is she's fighting
in the moment while the fight is happening on
top of that her suit is kind of like a grab bag
swiss army knife of weapons and useful items
and taskmaster easter eggs from the comics like
she does have taskmasters sword and shield from
the comics and the reason why she copies all the
avengers moves including spider-man's moves is
because she's watched all the footage from their
fights since the events of the first iron man
movie because like i said dracop has been doing
this taskmaster experiment for a long long time
the way he talks about it during the movie is
that he's been fighting the real war the shadow
war while the avengers have been busy fighting
the actual physical normal wars but yelnabalova
actually winds up being the one to kill drakoff
and even though you don't see the body you do see
his body go up in flames thousands of feet in
the air crashing in a big ship which also gets
blown apart at the seams so the movie is playing
it as if he's supposed to be perma-dead this time
black widow also manages to save antonia
taskmaster by giving her the antidote to
the chemical brainwashing that the other black
widows got they also wind up dosing all the other
black widows that are there in the red room at
the moment during this big fight allowing them
to escape before drake off in the red room wind
up blowing up and before our own thunderbolt ross
comes rolling up to try and arrest natasha again
i think part of the idea with that is that he's
also kind of giving her a bit of a pass because of
what she's done to take out drakoff in this threat
because he isn't stupid like he does recognize the
threat of the black widows in the red room and he
is probably really happy that she did all the work
for him but the other black widows do come back
to rescue yelena belova antonia taskmaster red
guardian and molina so that ross can't arrest them
too so at least after the events of avengers end
game minus natasha the whole family there is alive
but david harbor for instance said that he
wants to come back in captain america for
his red guardian that might wind up happening i
mean we'll see they haven't said much about it yet
but there's not really much of an ending scene
with thunderbolt ross he's barely in the movie
as it is but there is some foreshadowing in
easter eggs set up for say like the she-hulk
series which we're going to see next year in
potential red hulk earlier in the movie so at
the beginning of the movie when he's trying to
arrest natasha after the events of civil war
she makes fun of him saying that he's on what his
third triple bypass you don't look so good you're
embarrassing yourself and he does look very thin
like something is really wrong with him medically
he looks way worse than he did during civil war
and remember the black widow movie takes place
just a little while just a hot minute after the
end of civil war so theoretically his declining
health and implied connection to the weapons
plus program and present-day connection to the
thunderbolts what julia louis dreyfus's character
contessa valentina val madam hydra whatever you
want to call her is doing just makes it seem
like his health will continue to get worse
and that's where he might start experimenting
with weapons plus serums and that might lead him
to mcu red hulk at some point but also since
the black widows rescued taskmaster she's also
fair game to come back in the future working for
the contessa valentina val madam hydro whatever
but also because taskmaster is more about the suit
the tech they can always give the name to someone
else and do a more comic book accurate version
of the character but then there's a two week time
jump natasha's wearing yelena's jacket with all
the pockets which they spend a lot of the movie
couple big scenes establishing as the jacket from
avengers infinity war angie's changed her hair to
the infinity war short blonde cut so like her
costume is basically her infinity war costume
but now it makes sense why she looks like this she
uses mason who's like her supplier during the film
to get a quinjet and it's the same quinjet the
captain america secret avengers were flying around
when they show up in avengers infinity war if that
wasn't clear the quinjet that they were using the
entire time they were on the dl but she jokes with
mason that she just patched things up with one of
her families and now she's going to do it with
her other family the avengers by breaking some
of them out of prison which is a reference to the
raft so that sort of helps you chart where this
takes place in the timeline the scene right here
is meant to be happening right before the scene of
captain america showing up at the end of civil war
to bust them out of the rapt then they go on the
run for a couple of months until avengers infinity
war picks up but as she flies off the black widow
theme transitions to the version of the avengers
theme music and then you get the actual post
credit scene which is set after avengers end game
in present day but it's meant to take place before
the events of falcon and winter soldier in falcon
and winter soldier was about six months after
avengers end game so you have to imagine this
scene is like four or five months after avengers
end game it is yelling at belova coming to visit
natasha's grave in the midwest so if it wasn't
clear she's now buried in ohio in the same town
where they grew up in the beginning of the movie
for a couple years when they were children the
whole idea being that that was a very happy time
for their family like that was when she felt like
she had a family so that's why they buried her
there that's also why they made all those jokes
about the midwest during the scene she's driving
just a normal american pickup truck she has a dog
earlier in the movie she had said that if she had
the opportunity she'd always wanted to have a dog
she cleans up natasha's grave and is this really
sad somber moment but then they cut the tension by
having julia louis dreyfus character madame hydra
show up like a comedy ninja blow her nose and
start cracking wise about how terrible the
midwest is she also jokes that there's no way that
yelena is going to get a raise that she asked for
like yeah you and me both just reminding you
that valentina madame hydra is also working
for someone else which i think right now is kind
of implied is someone inside the us government
like thunderbolt ross just because of the team
she's setting up is basically mcu thunderbolts
but they also reveal that yelena has been working
for her for a good long while after the events of
avengers end game possibly even before that
they don't really explain when they initially
met each other and started working together but
she says she's going to be paid a ton of money for
this next job and she'll have the opportunity to
get revenge on the man responsible for natasha's
death and they reveal hawkeye's picture and he's
wearing his ronin costume from avengers end game
so the idea is that they'll cover the
events of that yelana going to kill hawkeye
during the hawkeye marvel disney plus series later
this year they haven't given us a release date for
that but it's supposed to happen during the fall
at some point so you wanted to wait that long for
them to pay this off maybe their martha moment
will be lucky the pizza dog like oh you're a
dog person too okay well you can't be all that bad
the bigger deal here though obviously is that val
whoever she's working for like maybe thunderbolt
ross as i said is implied are putting together
this thunderbolts team and they want hawkeye dead
for some reason and they're just taking advantage
of yelena misleading her making her think that
hawkeye is the reason that black widow died on
vormir when in fact it was way more complicated
and hawkeye was the one who actually tried to
sacrifice himself but black widow fought him and
won the honor of throwing herself off that cliff
the whole idea being that she was trying to save
both of her families and even though they never
make it clear in the black widow film if yelena
belova red guardian or molina were snapped but
i think it's implied that at least part of their
group was in part of the reason why black widow
was so willing to sacrifice herself is that not
only yes she was trying to save half the universe
and half of her family the avengers that got
snapped but she was also trying to bring back
some of her russian family who also probably
got snapped but thunderbolt ross or valentina
whoever she's working for in the us government
doesn't want yelena to know that so presumably
she'll find out after she catches up with hawkeye
during the hawkeye series but not before they have
at least some of a battle royale like their own
version of a budapest and there were some other
hawkeye references during the movie earlier when
she actually meets up with yelena in their safe
house in budapest like yellen asks what kind of
gun makes these holes and she points the wall
with a bunch of holes in black widow says oh those
aren't gun holes those are arrow holes and it's
implied that that's when hawkeye had come to try
and kill her before she decided to defect but the
other big connection here to marvel phase four in
the post-credits scene is that originally marvel
was going to release the black widow movie before
falcon and winter soldier so we were supposed to
meet julie louis dreyfuss's character here for
the first time and then see her show up on falcon
aware soldier to recruit us agent john walker but
either way the hawkeye series is the next place
we'll see yelena in the idea that now the mantle
of black widow has been passed to her inside the
mcu so she is the de facto main black widow that
will show up in the marvel movies they did talk
about doing black widow 2 but they said that it
would follow yelena's character like it would
be a black widow movie just about her but the idea
is also that yelena will show up during avengers 5
future avengers movies maybe even captain america
4 any of the ground level solo level marvel movies
are fair game and then she'd also probably show
up as part of this thunderbolts team that she's
a part of implied right now as julie louie drives
his character slowly putting it together but that
probably won't happen for a couple years there's
also a rumor that they're also setting up a dark
avengers project but that would be more of a
movie thing just because it's implied to be
much bigger characters much bigger scale but
everybody let me know in the comments if you
have any other big questions about what happens
during the post credit scene and how it sets up
future marvel phase 4 projects the marvel what
if series is coming up after the loki finale in
a couple weeks so i will be doing full what if
videos i've got a couple loki finale videos that
i'll post really soon i'm also working on a bigger
black widow full breakdown and easter egg video
for the entire movie that should post later this
weekend while you wait for everything everyone
click here for my full loki episode 5 video
and click here for all my other loki episodes
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!